[MUSIC PLAYING]
DARRYL JONES: Thank you very
much, thank you very much,
everybody.
Thank you for coming and
thank you for inviting me.
My name is Darryl Jones and
I'm interested in horror.
And I did indeed spend
far too much of my young
and probably far too much of
my middle aged life, as well,
reading and watching horror.
And one of the things
that those of us who
are interested in
horror, as scholars
like myself, as practitioners,
or as fans often
find ourselves having
to do is to defend
our chosen or beloved
area of interests.
Defend it against those
who think that somehow
an interest in horror is
suspicious, is bad for you,
that anybody who is too
interested in watching
horror movies must be a sick
person in search of ideas.
And I've noticed people in
the past sort of backing away
from me when I tell them
what I'm interested in
and what I work on.
So one of the reasons I
wrote this book is as--
not a defense of horror
because I don't really think it
needs defending, as I
don't feel defensive
about it, but as an explanation
of the enduring and continuing
appeal of horror, of its
centrality to culture,
that civilization is
inconceivable without some idea
of horror, that many of our
religious rituals and religions
are founded on ideas which
resembling their interest
in blood sacrifice, for example,
in torture, in cannibalism,
in subjects which we would
recognize from watching
and reading horror.
It's part of what we are.
It's part of what we do.
It's also-- and this is what
I want to talk about today--
an explanatory mechanism for
the world in which we live.
It helps us think
through the world,
it's a response to the world,
particularly its anxieties,
the anxieties of a given
culture at a given time.
So these are some
of the things that I
want to talk about today.
Just a quick show of hands.
Do we have any horror fans in
the congregation, first of all?
All right.
There's a small amount.
Do we have any people in the
audience that that find horror
difficult and are either, well,
frightened-- that's the point,
I suppose--
or repulsed by it?
A couple, at least.
OK.
I want to try and convince
you, not that you've been wrong
all along, I will
try to convince you
at least that I haven't
been wrong all along.
So, yeah.
This is a talk, then,
called Horror Today.
And it arises out
of the book and it's
a part of the last
section of the book
with some further extrapolation.
So the talk is divided
into two parts.
And in the first
part, I want to look
in general terms at the
location of horror today,
at least where I think
it is, where we are.
I'll end with a few pointers
to the future, a very dangerous
and very rash thing to do.
And in the second
part, I want to look
at one particular subgenre which
is climate change horror, eco
horror.
This is horror at its most
urgent and its most relevant.
If, as I believe,
we look to horror,
it can tell us things
about the world in which we
live as a means of interpreting
the world in which we live,
we would expect,
given that this is
our major contemporary anxiety.
I believe we would
expect that to be
quite a lot of eco horror.
So it offers for me a
powerful contemporary example
of the importance of horror
as a means of approaching
contemporary anxieties.
And more generally,
I think, as a way
of asking serious intellectual
and political questions.
So another thing I
believe is that horror
is-- as well as being
a visceral medium,
it is also an intellectual one.
So where is horror today?
This is the first
part of my talk.
The location of horror, I
think, moves with culture.
We may be seeing signs,
we are seeing signs
that it is moving
with geopolitics,
away from an American axis,
important Hispanic horror,
important Asian horror
in this century.
It may also be that
in my, at least,
concentration of horrors,
traditional media, fiction
and film, that we may not
be looking-- if we're not
looking in the wrong
places, we might be looking
in all the right places either.
A viewer of mainstream
Hollywood cinema
in the early 21st
century might well
have concluded that the genre
in this manifestation at least
was creatively moribund,
dead, or undead.
Cinematically, the
US film industry
appeared content to
allow younger directors
to plunder its back
catalog of horror films
in what seems like an endless
recycle of sequels, remakes,
and reboots, a corporate
production line, a wasteland.
And most particularly,
American cinematic horror
revisited landmark
films of the 1970s.
And the 70s does seem to be the
key decade for american horror.
In a 2016 Time Out experts poll
of the 100 best horror films,
6 of the top 10 films were from
the 1970s, and a further three
from 1968, 1980, and 1982.
68 was Rosemary's Baby, 80 was
The Shining, 82 was The Thing.
So around the 70s.
The only one outside of
that that orbit, I suppose,
was from the early
60s, was Psycho.
But apart from that, the top
10 was in a sort of long 1970s.
So they were, for example--
or they have been in this
century-- for example,
remakes of the Texas
Chainsaw Massacre,
1984, remade in 2003 with
subsequent sequels, as well.
Wes Craven's The Hills Have
Eyes, originally from 1977,
remade in 2006.
Carrie, 1976, the great Brian
de Palma movie remade in 2013.
This one starring people
you've actually heard of,
Chloe Grace Moretz,
Julianne Moore, and others.
And even, unbelievably,
unbelievably to me, at least,
two of the most notorious films
in the ultra controversial rape
revenge cycle of the 1970s,
Wes Craven's Last House
On The Left.
Keep telling yourself,
it's only a movie, only
a movie, only a movie.
And the first came out
in 1972, remade in 2009.
And-- oh, this is
Gaylord St. James,
the star of Lost House
On The Left in 1972.
I just put him in because I
want to draw your attention
to the fact that there is
an actor out there called
Gaylord St. James, so
Gaylord St. James, everybody.
So this Lost House On The Left.
And even I Spit On Your
Grave, originally from 1978,
remade in 2010.
Now, some of these 1970s films,
in and around their original
release, I think, particularly
Last House On The Left, Texas
Chainsaw Massacre, and
I Spit On Your Grave
were viewed as genuinely
dangerous cultural artifacts,
drawing the horrifying gaze of
legislators, judges, censors,
cultural commentators,
and the media.
They were banned.
These were amongst the
original video nasties
banned by the Video
Recordings Act of the 1980s
on the grounds
that simply viewing
these films could incite
viewers to go and commit
acts of violence.
Horror has always had
an uneasy relationship,
and sometimes quite a creative
relationship, with censors.
And I would regret--
and I think many
people would regret
if that relationship
wasn't there
because there is a
creative edginess to it.
Amd the history of
horror has always also
been the history of outraged
responses to horror.
Won't somebody think
of the children?
You know?
But the point that
I want to make now
with these remakes
of the 21st century,
their post-millennial
counterparts
tend to come and go unnoticed
because they don't matter.
We've lost something.
We've really lost something.
What have we got instead?
In terms of American horror,
well, Oren Peli's Paranormal
Activity from 2007, which
many of you will have seen,
I'm sure, was the most
successful horror film,
American horror film of the 21st
century, if not of all time,
until the release
of It last year.
In profit and budget
terms, Paranormal Activity
may be the most successful
movie ever released.
And viewed in
isolation, this film
is an exemplar of
post-millennial kind
of unhorrific horror.
It relies firstly on a
found footage technique,
which following the success of
the Blair Witch Project in 1999
has been overused in horror
films to the point of cliche.
And Blair Witch
itself, I should note,
although undeniably
brilliant, had
adapted his own found
footage technique
from the great Cannibal
Holocaust, the most notorious
of all the video nasties.
Paranormal Activity began a
self-recycling franchise which
has produced six films to date.
And there's nothing
distinctively contemporary
about this, nor is it
inherently problematic.
There's the element
of repetition,
of seeing the same thing
over and over again,
is an important concept,
an important aspect
of the pleasure we get
from watching horror.
One of the points I've
made before is that nobody,
and I mean nobody, went to
see Friday the 13th Part
9 or Saw 6 expecting
a completely different
cinematic experience
from the one that
got when they went to see
Friday the 13th part 8 or Saw 5.
What people want is to see
the same thing but slightly
different.
And the notion of a
cinematic horror franchise
goes back, at least as far as
universal horror, in the 1930s,
but viewed in the context
of a horror cinema, which
seems to have run out of
ideas, this repetition
may be just another sign
of creative bankruptcy.
And Paranormal Activity is
also the foremost exponent,
foremost modern exponent, of
the cinematic technique which
is most characteristic of
post-millennial American
horror, the jump shock or jump
scare, long periods of silence,
tense silence punctuated
by loud noises.
What film critic
Mark Kermode has
termed the
quiet-quiet-bang technique,
and sometimes known in
cinematic parlance as the bus,
in honor of a celebrated film
scene in the 1941 Val Lewton,
Jacques Tourneur "Cat
People," in which
a scene of great tension is
broken by the loud hissing
of buses' breaks.
Now, the jump shock is
undeniably effective,
but as a dominant technique it's
not horror or terror in the way
that these terms have
come to be understood.
Anyone can sneak up behind
you, shout boo very loudly,
and make you drop
your ice cream.
But this says nothing about
the state of your soul,
your place in the universe, the
social function of violence,
the evils of
political inequality,
nor any of the other
serious questions
that horror is
accustomed to asking.
So we shouldn't be looking
in American cinema,
but we might want to
look in Asian cinema.
We shouldn't be
looking primarily
in mainstream American
cinema, but there
are other places to look.
And here, obviously,
is one of them.
One that was released in
1992, Fran Rubel Kuzui's film
Buffy the Vampire Slayer
received mixed reviews
and passed without much notice.
Unsatisfied with both the
film and its reception,
it's right that Joss
Whedon tried again,
adapting it for television.
The first episode of Buffy the
Vampire Slayer was broadcast
on March the 10th, 1997--
Can it really be that long ago?
21 years ago-- with
Sarah Michelle Geller.
There she is, of course.
An authentic 90s scream
queen in the title role.
In that very same year, 97,
she also appeared in the neo
slasher films I Know What You
Did Last Summer and Scream 2.
So looking back from the
perspective of 21 years,
it's tempting to
view these moments
as marking a tectonic
shift in american horror.
Playing over seven
seasons from 97 to 2003,
Buffy developed into
a work and a world
of considerable complexity,
intelligence, and imagination.
The very antithesis of the
risk-averse, compromised,
moribund condition
of much mainstream
American cinematic horror
around the millennium,
which seemed incapable of
ever surprising its audience
or delighting them.
Buffy, of course, also came
into being with the internet
and so its success
was partly augmented
by the rise of the blogosphere
and by the online culture
of fandom.
It also captured the
academic imagination.
The subdiscipline
of Buffy studies,
combining institutional
academic criticism and theory
with fandom and unlicensed
criticism in the public sphere,
has produced a small library
of often very sophisticated
cultural and textual analysis.
Buffy was one of the early signs
that the millennial generation
was experiencing what
is often characterized
as a or the golden
age of television,
capital G, capital A,
capital T. From the Sopranos,
1990 to 2007, to The
Wire, 2002 to 2008,
to Breaking Bad, 2008 to 13,
to Game of Thrones, 2011 to 18.
The medium, television,
has shed much
of its cultural inferiority
complex relative to film.
First broadcast
in 2013, Hannibal
took the continuing story
of our great modern demon
to creative heights
seemingly foreclose the film
after Brett Ratner's
unforgivably lampoon 2002
adaptation of Red Dragon.
With seasons entitled Murder
House, Asylum, Coven, Freak
Show, Hotel, Roanoke,
Cult, and others,
American Horror Story,
first broadcast in 2011,
engages with the
satisfyingly familiar tropes
and locations of horror.
We like it because we know it.
The Louisiana-set first season
of True Detective, 2014,
drew explicitly on the history
of American weird fiction,
most particularly
with its references
to the Lost Land of
Carcosa, originally
to be found in Robert W Chambers
book, the King in Yellow,
and in the works
of Ambrose Bierce.
However, from a
historical perspective,
this golden age of
television might come
to be viewed as a last gasp.
It's a product of
a moment in which
the dominant cultural
medium of the second half
of the 20th century,
television, began
to be subsumed within the
dominant cultural medium
of the 21st, the internet.
So what might authentic
internet horror look like?
This might be a place to
look for horror today.
Well, one place to
look, for example,
might be in podcasts, such as
the hugely enjoyable fake radio
show, Welcome to Night Vale,
or the riotously inventive Down
Below the Reservoir.
But the brilliance
of these podcasts
rests on the actually
rather 20th century notion
that they are produced
and controlled
by highly creative auteurs,
Joseph Kink and Jeffrey
Cranor for Night Vale, Graham
Tuckwell for Reservoir.
Another distinctive internet
product, meme culture,
has the potential to
be all together more
dissented and anarchic, and
it may be uncontrollable.
Here is one example,
a famous one.
On June the 10th, 2009,
as many of you will--
I know-- be aware,
a pair of photo
shopped images appeared on
Something Awful, a comedy
website and online forum.
Credited to Victor
Surge, the photographs
showed two groups of
children photographed
in black and white.
In the background,
blurred and indistinct,
was a tall figure
dressed in black
and seemingly with
tentacles for arms.
This was, of course,
the Slender Man.
And beneath the images
with these captions,
beneath the image on your left
here, "We didn't want to go,
we didn't want to kill them,
but its persistent silence
and outstretched arms
comforted us and surrounded us
at the same time."
And for the image on
the right, "One of two
recovered photographs from
the Sterling City library
blaze, notable for being
taken the day which
14 children vanished
and for what is
referred to as the Slender Man.
Deformity cited as film
defects by originals.
Fire at library
occurred one week later.
Actual photograph
confiscated as evidence.
1986 photographer Mary Thomas
missing since June 13th, 1986."
And you can just see the figure
in the back of both photographs
there.
Lacking any kind of central
controlling narrative
beyond a vague but palpable
sense of menace and threats,
particularly to
children, the Slender Man
took on a life of its own as
a self-replicating evolving
internet meme recurring first
in user-generated creepy
pasta, online fiction, and
art, and in YouTube videos,
video games, and more generally
as an elusive cultural
reference.
On May the 31st, 2014,
as you may well know,
two 12-year-old
girls from Wisconsin
stabbed a classmate 19
times after a night reading
online Slender Man creepy pasta.
They did this,
they said, in order
to become the Slender
Man's servants,
to become his proxies.
Fears, real fears,
that the Slender Man
seems capable of infecting
reality and transforming it
have led to the most recent
of horror's ongoing series
of moral panics.
The case went to trial
in September 2017.
And the defense attorney claimed
that the girls-- and I quote--
"swirled down into
madness together."
The defendants, Morgan
Geyser and Anissa Weier
were sentenced to 40
years and 25 years
respectively in
mental hospitals,
the maximum sentences possible
for their respective crimes.
So it falls on each
generation then
to create its own
monsters, or at least
its own unique iterations
of monstrosity.
There's a good reason why
vampires cast no reflections
in the mirror, it's because what
looks back at us is ourselves.
We invest in monsters,
our own anxieties,
but sometimes also
our own desires
inarticulable in respectable
social discourse.
Monsters are the body for our
dreams and our nightmares.
But the internet is
too vast and too fast
for a talk of this length
or for a book of any size.
It's given horror an infinite
library in which to play,
an endless labyrinth
in which to hide.
The Slender Man is its most
distinctive monster thus far,
he's the scariest thing in
ages, but there will be others.
Part 2.
The world is dying.
It's our fault. And unless
we take radical action now,
it will be too late to
do anything about it.
The United Nations
Intergovernmental Panel
on Climate Change
report produced
this month, a
couple of weeks ago,
made for terrifying reading.
We are looking into
an apocalyptic future
of blistering summers, melting
ice caps, drowned cities,
whole portions of the planet
left effectively uninhabitable.
The death of coral, the
decimation of insect life,
dramatic resource scarcity,
unprecedented political
upheaval, population
migration on a scale we've
never seen before,
food and water wars,
the potential breakdown
of any social order.
Increasingly, many
of us have the sense
that we're living
through a horror movie.
The Walking Dead are
everywhere, on our screens
and at our ports, on our
streets and in our homes.
There's a widespread
sense of helplessness,
a wholesale lack of agency.
Horror, in fact, is the cultural
mode, as I've suggested,
uniquely suited to
articulating popular anxieties
in an understandable form.
And these are uniquely
anxious times.
Those of us who
watch and read horror
know that it is not
escapism for sickos,
as I suggested, but an
urgent explanatory mechanism
for the world around us.
President Donald
Trump's decision in 2017
to withdraw America
from the Paris Agreement
on Climate Change Action
followed a sustained campaign
of climate change denial
by the American right,
which brought together
the economic interests
of certain parts of
corporate America
with the cultural anti-modernity
of the evangelical religious
right.
While some media
outlets, such as the BBC,
have worked hard-- and in a way
which has often been terribly
self-damaging to
maintain a balanced view,
the response to global
warming in horror fiction film
and television over
the past two decades
has been virtually univocal.
Climate change is real,
the Earth is warming,
this is a man-made
disaster, our survival
is under severe threat.
Thus, for example, in M Night
Shyamalan's The Happening,
in 2008, plants begin
to release toxins
which are deadly to humanity.
Construction worker Curtis,
played by Michael Shannon,
begins to have apocalyptic
visions of a coming storm which
will decimate humanity in Jeff
Nichols' Take Shelter in 2011.
And the film closes with drops
of black rain, maybe oil, maybe
something altogether more
uncanny, falling from the sky.
Steroid-laden excrement
dumped into Chesapeake Bay
from an industrial
chicken rearing plant
creates a mutated strain
of flesh eating parasites
in Barry Levinson's genuinely
disturbing The Bay from 2012.
And the film is an extrapolation
of real-life environmental
concerns that manure runoff
from intensive poultry farms
was contributing to a number
of ecological dead zones
in Chesapeake Bay.
In Jeff Vandermeer's novel,
Annihilation, from 2014,
a team of scientists
investigates
the mysterious Area
X, a sealed-off area
of unknowable nature.
Vandermeer's novel
has been compared
to the work of the
great American ruralist,
philosophical ruralist, Henry
David Thoreau, whose 1851
book Walden is the great
American literary meditation
on the relationship between
humanity and the natural world.
Given widespread anxieties about
the melting of the polar ice
caps, it's not surprising
that the 21st century
has produced a good deal of
arctic and Antarctic horror.
Polar gothic is a recurring
subgenre of horror,
drawing on the long unexplored,
and thus fundamentally
imaginary, geography
of the polar regions.
A number of books of
horror and also a fantasy
have been set in the far
northern and far southern
latitudes.
Veneration of
Frankenstein, celebrating
its 200th anniversary this
year, takes place on board
the ship of the polar
explorer Robert Walton.
At the close of the
novel, Victor Frankenstein
heads out onto the
ice towards the pole
in pursuit of his monster.
Edgar Allan Poe's only
novel, The Narrative
of Arthur Gordon
Pym of Nantucket
follows its protagonist on
his inexorable journey south
towards its Antarctic climax.
Fresh out of medical
school, Arthur Conan Doyle
served for a time
as a ship's doctor
on a Greenland whaling voyage.
His story, The Captain
of the Pole Star,
is an imaginative
response to this voyage.
Heavily influenced by Poe,
HP Lovecraft's great novella,
At The Mountains
Of Madness, charts
the terrifying discoveries
of an Antarctic expedition.
All three film
versions of The Thing,
1951, there in the
middle, 1982, 2011,
so another contemporary remake
based on John W Campbell's 1938
novella, Who Goes There?
are set in polar latitudes.
Antarctica in 1938, 1982, and
2011, northern Alaska in 1951.
So polar horror, then,
is not a new phenomenon,
but it has gained
exponentially in intensity
in the last decades
Roland Emmerich's The Day
After Tomorrow opens
in the Antarctic,
where a slice of the ice shelf,
quote, the size of Rhode Island
breaks off due to
global warming.
A harbinger of the
climatic disaster
to follow in which the northern
USA becomes uninhabitable
and Mexico gives shelter
to American refugees.
This was the film which spurred
former Vice president Al
Gore to make his own influential
climate change documentary
film, An Inconvenient
Truth, in 2006.
And in 2017, a slice of the
Antarctic Larsen C ice shelf
did break off.
It was larger than Delaware,
which is half as big, again,
as Rhode Island.
So we've out-distanced our
fantasy already in 10 years.
In Larry Fesseden's film,
The Last Winter, from 2006,
an eco horror reimagining
of Algernon Blackwood's
classic work of Canadian
horror, The Wendigo.
In the last winter, the
melting of the permafrost
releases supernatural
entities, first
into a remote oil drilling
camp on the northern slope
of Alaska, and then it
is implied worldwide.
When Abby, played by
Connie Salas, the camp's
only survivor, wakes
up in hospital,
she hears news reports
about widespread disaster.
A doctor in the
room next door has
hanged himself
stepping outside, she
walks through puddles of
water, the snow has melted.
The hospital in which Abby wakes
at the end of The Last Winter
is presumably in Barrow,
Alaska, the northernmost city
in the US.
Barrow's isolation, cut off
from the world for long periods,
is what makes it vulnerable
to a vampire attack in 30
Days of Night in 2007.
The Last Winter's trope
of the melting polar ice
releasing forces inimical to
humanity recurs in The Thaw,
2009, with Val Kilmer
as a climate scientist.
The world is safe with Val
Kilmer as a climate scientist.
And also in the TV series
Fortitude, of 2015.
Fortitude was set in the
Svalbard archipelago,
the northernmost inhabited
place in the world.
And Svalbard is also the setting
for parts of Philip Pullman's
young adult fantasy
Northern Lights in 1995,
and for Michelle Pfeiffer's
remarkable retro ghost story
Dark Matter in 2010.
And there's me in
Svalbard last year.
Svalbard is also the home
of the Global Seed Vault,
protected there in
the permafrost in case
we ever need to
reseed the planet
in the wake of an
environmental catastrophe.
In 2016, unusually
high temperatures,
those same ones that
are causing the icecaps
to melt around Svalbard,
caused a flood of melt water
in to the vault's tunnels.
Meanwhile, back at
home, on our screens,
in Game of Thrones
the Night King
and his zombie army sweep
down from the frozen North
marching relentlessly towards
the Ice Wall that has kept them
at bay for millennia
and threatening
to wipe out humanity.
At the end of the last episode,
as many of you I'm sure
will know, an undead dragon
laid waste to the wall.
We are all holding our breath
to see what happens next.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 2: Excellent.
Thank you.
I think we have some time for
questions, about 20 minutes.
If you'd like to ask a
question, just put your hand up.
I'll come around and
get you a microphone.
AUDIENCE: You know?
Maybe it's just me, but I've
noticed that lately there's
been a trend in
horror to go for more
atmospheric kind of horror.
So I'm thinking of
movies like Hush,
the adaptation of Gerald's
Game, and most notably, I
think, The Haunting
of Hill House, which
is absolutely incredible.
DARRYL JONES: Don't
tell me about it
cause I haven't watched it yet.
AUDIENCE: You should.
It is incredible.
But, yeah.
Anyway, so I was
wondering, where
do you think this comes from?
The shift towards atmospheric
horror rather than gore?
DARRYL JONES: And I would say
it's there in fiction as well.
The old-fashioned
ghost story is back.
There was a time,
maybe a decade ago,
when the horror sections
had pretty much disappeared
from Waterstones and other
commercial bookstores,
but now they're back.
And old-fashioned ghost stories
have made a real comeback.
And you're absolutely right
about that this is something
that relies on the creation
of an unsettling mood
or atmosphere.
There's a couple of
things to say about this.
I think the first
thing to say is,
I think we've realized that
the jump tropfest is overdone,
it's a dead end, it
has nothing-- there's
no surprise left in that one.
Ultraviolence and
gore is many things,
but it's not generally scary.
It's shocking, it's
sometimes funny,
but it's rarely frightening.
I think the supernatural tale--
and, you know, although
I've been saving Hill House,
in fact, for the time when
I have a spare few days.
But I certainly know Shirley
Jackson's original novel
very well.
And these are tried
and tested narratives.
We know they work,
we know they work
in a strangely old fashioned
way because the sense
of the uncanny, of feeling
not at home with ourselves,
of not knowing whether the
foundations on which we base
our perception are real or not.
This is unsettling and
that's frightening.
And I think one of
the things we're doing
is rediscovering our sense of
this kind of unsettling fear.
So I think that's what
it is, that it works.
AUDIENCE: So climate change is
announcing itself for a while,
so there has been some time
to adapt this for horror.
Do you see any other
trends in horror
that are based on the current
developments in the world?
DARRYL JONES: Yes, I do.
There's quite a few of them.
We've seen interesting and very
kind of pointed development
of particularly american
horror arising out
of racial tensions
and inequality,
from Get Out to Detroit.
And Detroit is
definitely a horror film.
I don't know whether
you've seen--
I mean, it's a
Kathryn Bigelow film,
and Kathryn Bigelow is used to
mixing different kinds of modes
and genres in her
film, as anybody
who's ever seen Point Break will
know what kind of film is it.
And so Detroit is partly
a historical drama, partly
a cop movie, but very
largely a horror film.
I think a kind of home
invasion horror film.
So there's a new strain
of american racial horror,
I suppose we could call it.
The most obvious one to
me is-- and, again, this
is going over the
last decade or so,
since the global financial
crash of a decade ago.
It's no accident, I
don't think, that we
have seen a resurgence of
interest in Zombie culture.
What are zombies?
They are mindless,
undifferentiated, lumpen
proletarian mass completely
without any kind of control
or agency over their own lives,
they are completely powerless.
And many of us
have felt that way
in the wake of all of
the financial crises,
that we are enthralled to powers
beyond our comprehension which
we have absolutely no control.
So the feeling of being
the undead, or the living
dead, or the Walking Dead is
a very pressing one, I think.
So from Max Brooks' World War
Z, which slightly predates
the global financial crash, to
things like The Walking Dead
itself on television, to
films like The Girl With All
The Gifts, there's a lot of it
to the proliferation of zombie
walks in cities, something
I'm kind of interested
in, to online adverts
for zombie-proof homes.
All these kinds of things.
There's a real sense that the
zombie apocalypse is upon us,
because in some ways it kind
of is, as a way of thinking
about what's happening
to the world.
There's a famous
quotation that's
been ascribed to a number
of different thinkers,
to the effect that it is easier
to imagine the end of the world
than the end of capitalism.
Capitalism has suffered this
enormous existential shock.
It is as though the end
of the world has happened.
So all of these apocalyptic
zombie narratives,
that's another one.
I'm expecting a wave of
Donald Trump horrors,
if we aren't there already.
And I suspect they will be
of the King Kong, Godzilla
variety.
AUDIENCE: This is
not a question,
it's just to add on to that.
I think another trend that
I've noticed is tech horror,
so Black Mirror-esque
kind of shows, Ex Machina
comes to mind.
I think it's just
people are freaking out
about what's going on in terms
of artificial intelligence
and security, and
all sorts of things.
So maybe that's relevant.
DARRYL JONES: Yeah.
I'm a bit nervous to say
this in front of you, guys,
but I think that this
is absolutely right.
And I think that the
developments of the internet,
which--
I mean, I'm of a
generation that is too--
I can't really go there,
my daughter's generation
[INAUDIBLE] but, you know, the
developments of the internet,
particularly of social media
within less than a generation,
half a generation,
incredibly quickly,
has proven
psychologically almost
impossible to assimilate with
the speed that it's happening.
And that's my grandkids.
And it may destroy us all.
I mean, we may be about to
witness the end of democracy
as a consequence of the fact
that we cannot assimilate
the implications of social media
quickly enough at the speed,
which is happening.
So I'm not surprised to see
a swave of techno horror.
I mean, mad science of various
kinds has always been--
there have always been anxieties
about scientific advancements
and discoveries.
And, as I said, the 200th
anniversary of Frankenstein.
And I think the link or the
line from things like Ex Machina
is a very, very real one.
And it's interesting that
the Victor Frankenstein,
the demiurge, the creator, the
mad scientist of Ex Machina
is, of course, a search
engine tech wizard.
AUDIENCE: I've also
noticed in recent horror
the trend to focus
on human connection
sometimes, like in
Stranger Things, and even
The Haunting on Hill House.
And there is this
game, the simulacra,
that discourages
use of social media
by turning social media
into a monster of sorts.
Do you think this is like
a general trend in society
of encouraging genuine
human connection,
or is this an expression of
our fear of disconnecting,
or is this just
something to encourage
people to get into horror?
[LAUGHTER]
DARRYL JONES: I don't
know the answer to that.
Oh, I'm having a middle-aged
person's senior moment now.
What was the name of the
social media horror film
that came out a few years ago?
Ugh.
Anyway--
AUDIENCE: Unfriended.
DARRYL JONES: Unfriended.
Unfriended.
That's the one.
Yes.
And one of the things that
that film, which in many ways
is a very conventionally
structured teens in peril
sort of movie that we've
seen from Halloween to Final
Destination, know to,
I suppose, even things
like Ring, but with
an online difference.
One of the things that
viewers and critics
of a certain age asked
about Unfriended is,
why not just turn the
bloody internet off?
You know?
Why not just disengage
with social media?
And, clearly, one of the
points that this has to make
is of the impossibility of
a meaningful life offline.
That there's a whole
generation for whom this is--
you might as well
say, stop breathing.
And this is disturbing.
But one of the things that
it's also worth saying
is that horror is a
generational thing.
And so each generation
finds its own monsters.
And each generation
is rendered obsolete
by the monsters of
the next generation.
So it may well be that in saying
these things, I am simply--
what I'm saying is that this
is no longer-- you know,
I'm very comfortable talking
about 1970s and 1980s horror
because that's what
I grew up with.
It may well be that
what I'm saying is,
I don't understand
the modern world
and this is frightening to me
because it means I'm obsolete
and about to die.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for the talk.
Given the strong connection
between horror and culture,
what do you think that
makes a good movie that
is, like, scary,
like everywhere,
like The Shining is scary.
It doesn't matter if
you're from anywhere,
it's kind of good in any case.
DARRYL JONES: You know?
I think the answer
to this is in part
a very old fashioned
answer that--
and it's there in the
theory of classical drama.
It's been there.
It's the way we've
understood art since we've
had art to understand.
The way we understand
narrative is
in the classical unities,
unities of time, of place,
of action.
Now, what this means for
a film like The Shining
is one location, one series of
events, one winter, at least.
There are films like Rec, the
Spanish zombie movie which
narrows it down even further.
One apartment building
in Barcelona, one night,
one attack of zombification
or whatever it is.
So the concentration on the
effective, tried and tested
narrative forms
works really well.
There's a reason why these
narratives and these ways
of telling the
story have survived
through centuries and millennia,
and it's because they work.
The building of an
unsettling atmosphere
is genuinely important.
There's a debate amongst
practitioners of horror
as to how much should
you show and whether that
what is truly
horrifying is that which
we create in our own
imaginations or that
which the screen shows us.
And at different times there
have been different answers
to that.
So with technological
advancements,
sometimes horror tends to
get more spectacularly gory.
You want somebody
reaching down their throat
and turning
themselves inside out.
You could probably do that now.
You couldn't do that two
generations ago at least,
you know?
So these kinds of things.
So there's a debate going on
as to how much we should show,
what's most effective.
But my feeling about it is--
and maybe I tend to be kind
of old-fashioned in this--
that the things that
work we've known
that they worked for centuries
and millennia, we update them,
we modify them.
So that's the answer, I think.
SPEAKER 2: Thank you
very much, Darryl Jones.
[APPLAUSE]